must be temporary
that's like uh
I think
yes
I think the gcts people manage that so
once yes
okay great thank you representative
leishman
um what we've done in the past for these
is
um
kind of redundant with what Mike cane
presented this morning and then we would
get into some program information
only to find that the agencies would
come in
a few weeks later and the issues were
different so what we've decided to do is
kind of
um
reiterate some of the points from Mike
Kane's presentation focus on a few areas
I'm going to talk about the what the
budget analysts do for the divisions
and then a little bit about the process
and the schedule and then we can either
wait to the end for questions or you can
tell me to hold and uh I'll answer them
as we go if I can we'll take questions
sounds good so what I've put in front of
you is uh you may have gotten this I
think you've got this from
representative Leachman already we've
updated it with phone contact
information on the top but it's it's a
list of our analysts and
what agencies were assigned to so the
first two columns of this page are
division one
and even though the agencies are listed
under each of our names
we can help you with anything you can
ask Melissa for things that I cover I
can help you with things she covers
however however it works best for you
we're here
we've also attached the business cards
which
not too many people probably use anymore
but it's an invitation for you to feel
free to uh call us whenever you need
something
I've also attached to this a list of the
division one agencies and this is a
report that we run called the biennial
budget analysis
in the four columns
um
after the description the first four
columns are the general fund and this
report gives you the 2020 actual
and the 2021 adjusted authorized and if
I could stop for a minute on the
adjusted authorized
because we're still working on the
budget before that year finishes it's an
approximation of what that year will be
it's probably slightly overstated
because in the actual numbers we have
elapsed that wouldn't be included in
that number
and then we have the legislative
recommended columns
the general fund share and then the four
columns to the right are just the total
funds
so as we get the information from the
governor's face we can run this on the
governor's budget request and see
what that looks like for the coming
biennium
so you might wonder why they're two of
us in division one
because of the
variety of
different kinds of information and
requests and the number of fiscal notes
more than half of the fiscal notes
have to do with division one subject
matter
so we tend to get the bulk of that work
so at some point in time they decided we
need two people in division one
a little bit about what we do
we will be present at all of the public
hearings and work sessions
um
that way we keep up with the bills that
we're following
will make sure that the public has the
correct number of copies and all that
kind of logistical details
um we prepare all amendments for House
Bill One hospital two
and then all the other bills that come
before the committee
typically if the division as a group
decides to go forward with an amendment
we'll have that drafted and that the
name of the chair
but if any individual member wants
something that they want to propose this
amendment we'll put it in their name
we'll keep it in our binder until we're
asked to hand it out
sometimes we'll prepare an amendment and
the member will decide I don't want to
do it so it it doesn't see the light of
day it goes on a big pile back at the
office and at the end of the session we
may need it later or we just recycle it
so feel confident that if you have an
idea you can share it with us we can
have it in the proper form and ready to
go
and then you can decide what to do with
it
we look at the house calendar every week
to see what's coming to the floor from
other committees sometimes those
committees will make an amendment to a
bill that did not have a fiscal impact
but the amendment does have physical
impact there may be an appropriation or
there may be something that impacts
Revenue we keep an eye on those every
Friday
um just as to to alert the chair
we're not involved with the decision of
what goes where but we just flag things
to make sure that nothing gets through
the cracks
we have uh seven bills referred to
finance now or more than seven but I
think at least three of them have to do
with division one
um regarding the uh retirement subject
matter Melissa was in touch with Marty
Carlin the other day and he offered to
visit the division
and provide a briefing if
if that's something you're interested in
to kick off the uh
the session
we also keep the materials on our
website currents so that you'll be able
to
within a few days see the the items that
the agencies present or things that are
handed out
follow-up materials we'll uh we'll stay
on the agencies to make sure that you
get the things that you asked for which
often happens during the presentation
you'd like to see some history or some
more detail on a program
going back to the invitation for us
next week
no no apparently Carol yeah plus I went
to the Marty gave a presentation in Edna
because this session and I went to that
so I've sort of heard it already but I I
think it's worth doing again I actually
haven't mentioned a little bit but yeah
so um
any time for me
sure we can do that
okay
right here so it's a pretty complicated
mess especially
huh
I
think another interesting guy is right
down
who runs our 457 okay which is related
it but it's separate from the
requirements we want to get together
with my contact information yeah do you
know I've heard the name yes
yes we can we can reach up hours
sure
so representative is a camera
okay I'm sorry Mr brief introduction he
probably had a hard time finding where
we were no I apologize if it's a
cafeteria oh yeah
so I apologize
if you have any questions feel free to
ask and as I said earlier there's no
questions that are
this book right here just represents
what we deal with in division one and
you can see all the different College
camps Maybe
all those are all the different agencies
that I've tagged from the last budget so
this is a lot there and you'll find
assistance we have here is invaluable
they keep us up to me
like a daily basis when we're doing the
budget they'll consent a sheet similar
to this and it will have all the changes
in that particular day and sometimes it
goes on with behavior
very helpful as I mentioned earlier I
grew back there is available for you as
well
thank you so much and thank you and it's
an honor to be here I do love numbers
so continuing on with what we do uh Mike
Kane mentioned this morning in the very
end of the package
we've got a
Amendment packet
that shows you all the house bill one
and House Bill 2 amendments and this
happens to show division one
which uh because I worked on this I
decided to include that
but it gives you a picture of how just
how many amendments to House Bill 2
there are it starts almost at the top of
that page and continues on to the next
so we'll have three kinds of
three kinds of actions will either
Amanda section because we like what's in
there but
it needs to be improved
there may be a section the division says
no we don't want to do that so we'll
delete the
and then there will be new sections
where there's something that is budget
or maybe not budget related but related
to the overall finances that the
division would like to see so we'll add
it so
that just gives you kind of a a quick
look at the activity from last time
so at the end of the process we'll
prepare that the committee will vote and
then we prepare materials for a finance
briefing to the Full House
sometimes it's in 210 to 11 sometimes
it's in the chamber
and it's kind of a highlights of the
budget uh bullet main points and that's
presented the week of the vote
um to share with the full membership the
uh the proposed amendment
after that we repeat the same process
for the Senators
and then after the Senate phase we come
together and support both the house and
the senate for the committee conference
and what we do for that is we'll have a
detailed change document that shows
what the Senate
changed
from the house amendments then we'll
have a side by side packet that's all of
the house bill one sections and the
house bill two sections
that way you can look across the page
see what the Senate added see what they
changed see what they took out
so talking a little bit about the
process Mike touched on the agency phase
they started that last spring
they have to update the chart accounts
and they have to get all the positions
every full-time position
in the state has a specific record in
the in the budget systems and they
account for
step increases
um
benefits some people have
a two-person plan and then they have a
child so now it's a family plan but they
account for all that and update that
information
they prepare a
budget development guide for the
agencies and this is given to them in
August
and it has all the nitty-gritty details
of what they need to do to prepare their
budget and they actually
we see class lines in the budget when
the agencies work they go a level lower
to object code levels so there's a lot
of detail in there
and their tables in there that explain
what the different classes are intended
for and it's handy we won't use it a lot
but when we're looking for something
that's there
so the agencies prepare their go ahead
let me try let me take let me take a
shot at it um
class 40 indirect costs think of it as
an overhead charge
so you have a federally funded account
but
that activity
creates a little cost for the state in
terms of personnel I.T support all those
administrative things so it's like an
overhead charge class 40.
federal or other funds
class 41
is audit set aside well there's three
together so 41 is a charge on those
Federal and other funds to pay for
audits
it's like .001 percent
so you'll see it on fiscal committee
items they have that line adding and it
usually you can look at the digits and
lines up with a total amount
class 42
need those audits
LBA does the Audits and they hire KPMG
to do the annual report work and some
other
some other audits that they engaged the
outside Auditors for
class 42
and part of the confusion is the title I
think they call it additional fringe
benefits
so if I'm a state employee and I work in
an account that's funded by federal or
other funds
it's
it's a share of what my retirement costs
because if my job is funded
by an outside Grant why should the state
pay for my retirement
there's also a 64.
for the other agencies like Department
of Transportation they're all highway
fund or fish and game and that 64 is a
charge for retirement costs
of currently retired people
so they're both for retirement costs 42
is for people who are currently working
funded from another source 64 is
for the costs of retirees from state
government that worked for like Highway
fund or fish and game
your retirement in class 60 correct
correct but if it's somebody
Des or something that's
so Grant
there'll be a class 42 and there
wouldn't be
there could be if it's a split funded
account
and then there's a little bit of a
calculation there how much is general
how much is other
so the agent agency phase not much else
to say about that except for the summary
on 95 to 99 I think Mike cane touched on
uh the efficiency budget versus the
additional prioritized needs
efficiency budget used to be called the
maintenance budget I like to think of it
as
the cost to do what you did last year
without adding new programs but
accounting for
inflation and things like that
additional prior priority prioritized
needs are things that you'd like to do
above and beyond and those are
prioritized from one to ten
an interesting example that you'll see
coming up here is there's a
a bill to
fund some water grants
and environmental services
and that's a general fund cost now those
grants have been approved
the rewarded grants the agreements went
to government Council but for some
reason they're in the additional
prioritized needs when you would think
they would be in the efficiency budget
so we'll probably have that conversation
when we see that bill
and that's where uh these definitions
have a real a real real meaning because
the agencies will come in and talk about
the governor's budget and what they did
get and what they didn't get and then it
would be interesting for the members to
say well you didn't get this what
priority was it was it number one was it
number ten
yep
it's pretty nervous
so administrative services will take all
his agency requests
bundle them up into one package present
them to the governor through his budget
director
and the governor will hold hearings
usually around the time of Thanksgiving
all the agencies come in talk about
their budgets and what their needs are
and that's sort of input into the
governor's process
the governor will present his budget
around I think in his uh
inaugural address he said around
Valentine's Day
and then shortly after that he's invited
to house finance for presentation which
he will open make some remarks and then
the budget director will remain to
answer your questions
and that's usually
um here in 210 211 and the Senate
Finance members are also invited
and in the past right after that some of
the first agencies had started to make
their presentations
finance will start working on bills
very soon and then once we get the
budget and the presentation
um we'll we'll be able to start hearing
from agencies and doing the budget work
deadlines page 22 of Mr Kane's document
has the house deadlines and I wanted to
add a little bit to that if I could
the last data report is March 30th
in order to report the full committee
will have will have to have voted which
means each division makes presentation
so for that to work and get to the
clerk's office that week of March 30th
the beginning of the week would be
presentations from the divisions to the
full committee
which means the week before that
the divisions should have at that point
wrapped up their work
it's not always smooth like that this is
kind of how it would be in an ideal
situation
so the
full committee votes
we put together the Amendments house for
One hospital two working with OLS into
the right format
goes to the clerk ready to go on the
floor and then
there's the briefing to the full house
before the vote and we we help by
preparing the
the brief The Briefing document with you
know bullets and highlights run it by
the chairs tweak it and then
we all show up in the in the the hall
and
it's sometimes it's well it's very well
attended sometimes it's not but we all
stay in the room in case the questions
if if the questions get too detailed we
can we'll have our notebooks and we can
we can help out with that
so that provides about five weeks
the thing to keep in mind of the five
weeks is
there's a town meeting day on March 9th
there's President's Day on the 20th of
February
uh might be might be a difficult day to
get agencies to come in
and there are possible snowstorms so if
you think about the five weeks
um
it can get eaten up quickly and by the
way there's session days sometimes
they're two a week so it goes really
fast
by contrast the Senate has from April
April 7th to June 2nd so they have
almost seven and a half weeks and
fresher Revenue information
so that's really all I wanted to go over
um kind of repetitive from what Mike had
this morning but uh
it'll be it'll be much more fun when we
get the agencies in here and they can
start telling us about their budgets
foreign
they may have more time but they have
fewer people that's true and
the level of experience I don't think
unfortunately this term was quite there
right
one thing about the senate for us is
there are three divisions of finance and
we staff all three
when the budget gets to the Senate
there are four of us and there's one
committee and they're not always talking
about division one stuff so we can get
other things done
and and you're right about the new
members
um
we also
dig in over here house 10 house finance
tends to get into some detail and then
we go to the Senate and because of their
numbers they're at a higher level
and they'll ask us questions and we know
the answers because we just lived
through it so they tend to think that
we're smarter than we really are yeah
and it's been a history as long as I've
been here
foreign
thinking so I do have a couple of
questions I don't know if I have to have
this one the first one's easy so for the
bills that are currently referred to
finance are the hearings before the full
Finance commit and then what okay and
then you
know the full financing money will be
kind of like the 30 000 for about
something and then we get down okay
every bill that comes to the full
finance committee is a rule it comes to
a specific division of that agency
okay so then the other question I had
was I'm trying to figure out how we work
with Ways and Means because we're sort
of going through our process of the
budget right but we don't really have
the ways and means estimate run or how
does that all
onto this division for example
so we'll see them first and I'll go the
whole Community don't come with this
division recently
so we've seen like enormous
Susan on it so we'll see that what they
have so we have some idea what to work
with and then
um oftentimes leadership or the chair of
the committee will say I'd like you to
this will be your number
my good friend Jess Edwards work hard to
get as much money for that division but
we'll push this to start
and when do they
I think this morning Mike said toward
the end of March
so they've had a chance to do their work
it's always been a good report
I'm excited to work with you guys this
session I did do I started last year so
I haven't done a budget session on this
side but
um at my as Mike Kane had stated I came
from revenue so I'm used to working with
ways and means on that side so I'm
excited to learn this budget side and
and help you guys through the process
so
the reason I had a question about I
noticed in the spreadsheet that treasury
has a really big number is that because
that's what they're paying off bonds
with is
so the real spending is not anything
like this number right and that's
something when
when you the parties get together and
figure out which division has so much of
a Target
there's certain things you can't really
do much with like Debt Service so and
treasury will make a presentation to us
as well and we'll see let's split them
okay
um
yeah so there was something else I
wanted to ask
oh I remember
um I I just wanted to Second what the
representative Weiler said over there
which is the performance audits are a
great source of knowledge and and while
we're waiting for February 15th now we
have our list of agencies it might be a
good idea especially for the really big
ones like
I don't know Corrections one in my
office liquor there you go liquor
Corrections Etc
um to to go through those performance
audits right and and because there's a
list of problems right boom you know and
often they'll say
in the previous performance audit five
years earlier the same problem is there
right so so that's a good thing you can
ask them about you know what are you
doing about this thing whatever it is
that's an excellent point because
several of us that I have are still sit
on pistol and we get notifications
performance and financial audits very
detail we supposed to say about it the
mission to do a great job and it's Dan
mentioned
sometimes agencies both years without
preventing problems if it's any time to
really put there to be to the buyer it's
when it important
yes
by the disappointing thing I mean the
lva auditor does such a great job and
something since don't get corrected
and anonymously
give us a chance for most agencies of
the course
of that how do you decide who's going to
be audited if everyone
continue
there's a committee for the performance
audits they make recommendations
there's uh Financial audits are more of
a cyclical thing
um those audits we have a an audit
section of our website and they list
them by agency which is really handy so
if you could find out not based on when
it happened but on the actual topic
so that's kind of Handy and if you're
interested in a hard copy if you prefer
that they tend to keep most of them for
for a long time so chances are we can
provide a hard copy of it if you if
you'd like
whatever
situation
pages so it's interesting good to get
the iron copy so you may know it's like
the lighter one over there
yes
this guy gave me an idea maybe it should
leave for a couple of the big ones so
hey you'll read the letter one and I'll
read the corrections
and that way
at least not rather than just sort of
take a look if I just yeah yeah that's
an excellent
so we can uh would you like to prepare a
list of the most consent sure
probably yeah
there are other agencies like licensure
that had some issues in the course
philosopher q a licensure how many
different little agencies are under them
I know almost everything you need to be
be licensed to do in this state so
that's something being overseas
with like the character of Suits our
Birds
so both financial and performance
both
many years ago of the University of
Science academic division certain
budgets in a specific one
prevention
might show up and he did speaking on the
judicial range
last session there was a letter to say
that possible mechanics among some of us
the judicial branch Center for outside
half a dozen would judge it it's a
number of things that we accept as a
letter but not
recommendations so that means something
before the judicial branch are they
working to build some of those
specifications
house
that'd be a good fight too might be a
good time
that licensing if they don't want to
believe because if there's any questions
like mascara
that was a reason why I thought about
that
so you already have a good volunteer to
your device
and what about we've been around a while
and other agencies maintaining private
public works computer
is
[Music]
or is that uh the oversight the audit
committee or is it
the exact process
I'm not familiar with but I can get you
the complete summary of how it works
sometimes
and then we have them returning to try
to progress like the liquor commissions
required how to provide a select orderly
updates
for that enforcement audit yes
thank you
to thank the other ones that generate
the list
it's just some cheers
I'm trying to think
now we've had a lot of audits in that
session
and their new Department yeah
that's a good point because you knew um
and there was a lot of angst in here let
me set that up two years from my
Institution
so if you want to really dig into the
budget I'd like to know that I'd like to
know that it's your purpose all right
yeah
and maybe their components happen
like the puc or the yeah
I don't care anything any thoughts
thank you
because five seconds
you're not always as
before the time
in a few years that's probably not
another decade now the legislature
vehicle before
the agency a month it's a the
legislature used to not know
exaggerations almost require that they
get permission right
and then those chocolates you know
agency status but there's still an
agency in the state so they have a
responsibility they shouldn't be closing
record stores without some notice and
that's
and that's so a little more transparency
again I think
116 million dollars is something that
was fun to just provided to save it
there's there's got to be a little
recent we've had some issues with
enforcement about those jobs
and they're making some progress again
the liquor here
indicates like the last
the most recent list sure
I know every setup
usually happens
especially the ones that you can keep
those heads okay
one last thing that I I included but
didn't talk about
in these three pages the last page is
just an example of the governor's
budget
and in the past the committee has worked
with this document for their budget work
because it has the two history years and
it has the position counts down at the
bottom of the page
so there have been years where the
Committees worked with just the house
bill one format but it doesn't doesn't
give you the history or the positions
so that's probably whatever the chairs
decide that's probably what we're going
to end up working with so I included it
thank you
foreign